[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend
während zu Hause über die gasumlage
debattiert wird bemüht sich der Kanzler
im Ausland neue Energiequellen zu
erschließen und es war klar dass er von
seiner Reise in die Golfstaaten nicht
mit ganz leeren Händen zurückkommen
würde dann hätte er sie vermutlich gar
nicht erst angetreten so konnte heute
präsentiert werden was in den letzten
Wochen ausgehandelt wurde die
Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate werden
flüssig Erdgas nach Deutschland liefern
Andreas Kühnast beobachtet den Besuch
des Kanzlers am Golf
der Tag beginnt mit 20 spitzenden
deutschen die durch Abu Dhabi geführt
werden also durch den ganz speziellen
Teil den die Herrscherfamilie dieser
Delegation gezeigt wissen will auch der
Kanzler schwitzt und leidet ein bisschen
unter den 34 feuchtheißen Grad als er
den künstlich geschaffenen Mangrovenwald
auf der Insel ju Bale erst bestaunt und
dann vergrößert alle drei Golfstaaten
die Scholz bereist wollen ein grüneres
Image und ein neues Geschäftsmodell
dabei sind die Deutschen wegen des alten
da als Scholz im Schatten am Rande des
arabischen Wäldchens über sein Reiseziel
spricht spielen Mangroven keine Rolle
nämlich unser viele Regionen
konzentrieren die uns die Möglichkeit
verschaffen unsere Energieversorgung zu
gewährleisten und dass man eine
Abhängigkeit hat von einem Lieferanten
und auch von dessen
Entscheidungen abhängig ist das wird uns
sicherlich nicht wieder passieren dass
Deutschland eine erste Lieferung
verflüssigtes Gas nun auch aus den
Emiraten bekommen wird ist politisch ein
Meilenstein und praktisch ein Steinchen
die vereinbarte Menge entspricht weniger
als einer tageslieferung pipeline-gas
der etwas unentschiedene Applaus dürfte
nicht nur dem ersten Tanker gelten
sondern vor allem der Hoffnung auf
weitere
der Chef der deutschen Regierung wird
von einigen der mächtigsten Chefs der
deutschen Wirtschaft begleitet die
kamerascheuen CEOs von Siemens Energy
SAP Airbus und ThyssenKrupp Klettern mit
in den regierungsflieger in den drei
Monarchien die Scholz in zwei Tagen
abfliegt sind Menschenrechte nicht viel
wert Scholz spricht das Problem
öffentlich zurückhaltend an sogar im als
ausbeuterstaat bekannt gewordenen Katar
zwei Monate vor der Fußball-WM betont
der Gast das Positive zur Kenntnis
nehmen wir dass es auch Fortschritte
gibt in Fragen um die lange gerungen
werden musste etwa was die Situation von
Beschäftigten betrifft auch wenn das
noch lange nicht den Vorstellungen und
spricht die wir selber haben der Spott
der sich über die besonders tiefen
Verbeugungen von Wirtschaftsminister
Habeck agoss dürfte Scholz nicht
entgangen sein als er auf terminbinhamat
altani den Emir von Katar trifft wählt
er das blicken Deutschland bittet um
kurzfristige Gaslieferung
Qatar will langfristige Verträge
konkreter wird es hier nicht
es gibt Gespräche zwischen Katar und der
deutschen Seite über eine Partnerschaft
die wir vertiefen wollen
noch ein zwei Lungenzüge arabischer
Weihrauch dann zurück in den Deutschen
Herbst es bleiben noch keine großen
Abschlüsse nach dieser Reise es bleibt
ein kleines Bäumchen im arabischen Sand
der Verursacher der neuen deutschen
gaspolitik eskaliert derweil seinen
Krieg putin hatte zwar nur von einer
Teilmobilmachung gesprochen doch es
gehen so viele einzugsbefehle an Männer
die keineswegs militärisch trainiert
sind das selbst Prominente
putinpropagandisten die stirnrunze
jedenfalls wenn es sich um ethnische
Russen handelt die machen aber nur einen
geringeren Teil der einbezogenen aus ein
Großteil der Männer wird in den ethnisch
nicht russischen Regionen der Föderation
eingezogen in asiatischen Regionen oder
in muslimischen Gebieten des Kaukasus
was auch eine Form von kolonialer
Herrschaft ist Christian sem berichtet
fünf Tage nach Verkündung der Teil
Mobilisierung wächst in Russland der
Widerstand in der Teilrepublik Dagestan
etwa weigern sich Männer in den Krieg zu
ziehen Frauen stellen sich schützen vor
sie die Polizei geht mit Warnschüssen
dazwischen
wer kann versuchten diesen Tagen noch
wegzukommen aus Russland Staus nach
Finnland nach Georgien in die Mongolei
Flüge sind kaum noch zu kriegen doch in
Russland gibt es auch Zustimmung für
putinskurs
ich bin bereit für die Mobilmachung ich
warte auf die einen Berufung das dient
dem Schutz unseres Heimatlandes wir
kämpfen gegen Faschisten
das stört mich nicht wenn es notwendig
ist
bislang konnten die Menschen das was in
der Ukraine passiert weit wegschieben
aber die Teilen Mobilisierung hat das
schlagartig geändert
viele Befürworter unterstützen den Krieg
nur unter der Bedingung dass er irgendwo
weit weg ist und sie nicht persönlich
betrifft ihre Meinung wird sich nicht an
einem Tag ändern ihre Meinung über den
Krieg und Putin wird sich erst innerhalb
von Wochen oder Monaten ändern
in jakutskreisen mutige Frauen die
Polizei ein
und landen im Gefangenentransporter
und in Sankt Petersburg kennen die
Sicherheitskräfte mal wieder keine Gnade
brutal schlagen sie gestern auf der
monstranten ein das harte Vorgehen kein
Zufall die Brutalität hat eine neue
Dimension erreicht das fällt besonders
auf
das Ziel Demonstrationen gegen Putin
gegen die teilmobilisierung schon im
Keim ersticken wer hier hinkommt braucht
viel Mut
gerne würden wir mit den Demonstranten
oder Demonstranten sprechen warum sie
hier sind doch wer mit den Medien
spricht und Interviews gibt dem droht
die sofortige Festnahme auch das ist neu
in den letzten Jahren konnte man zusehen
wie der Raum der Meinungsfreiheit in
Russland immer kleiner wurde und jetzt
ganz zu verschwinden droht als wir am
Mittwoch bei den Protesten in Moskau
drehen interviewen wir einen
Demonstranten
unsere Leute dürfen nicht sterben unsere
Mütter haben schon
die Polizei macht kurzen Prozess ifgeni
wird festgenommen später erfahren wir er
muss 15 Tage in Haft der Vorwurf
Ungehorsam gegen die rechtmäßige
Anordnung eines Polizeibeamten und es
droht die direkte Einberufung von der
Zelle weiter an die Front plötzlich ist
Putins sogenannte spezialoperation in
der russischen Gesellschaft angekommen
und viele spüren jetzt dass in Russland
noch harte Zeiten drohen
Putin hat auch Strafe für Deserteure
drakonisch erhöht es setzt außerdem
darauf dass seine Soldaten große Angst
davor haben in ukrainische
Gefangenschaft zu kommen weil sie wissen
wie ukrainische Gefangene von den Russen
behandelt werden
diese Fotos zeigen einen der asof-style
Kämpfer bevor sich sein Regiment in
mariopold gab und dann nach seiner
Befreiung aus russischer Gefangenschaft
bei dem Gefangenenaustausch kamen auch
fünf Briten frei die auf ukrainischer
Seite gekämpft hatten einer von ihnen
hatten britischen Medien jetzt von
täglichen Folterungen berichtet auch
deshalb hat Präsident selensky eine
videoansprache auf Russisch gesendet
gerichtet an russische Soldaten wir
behandeln euch entsprechend der Genfer
Konvention für Kriegsgefangene ihr habt
nichts zu befürchten wenn ihr euch uns
ergibt
derweil tobt der Krieg weiter und
Russland betreibt seine scheinreferenten
weiter unsere portatauge Bode ist in der
Region saporiscia
auch heute ist die Schlange der Autos
wieder hunderte Meter lang sie stehen
vor dem ersten Checkpoint der von der
Ukraine kontrollierten Seite des
bezirksapodicia Olga und Alexey haben es
geschafft bis gestern lebten sie noch
unter russischer Besatzung mit Tränen in
den Augen erzählt Olga wie das
sogenannte Referendum auf der anderen
Seite abläuft nun
am 23 haben sie mit dem Referendum
angefangen sie sind von Haus zu Haus
gegangen und haben gefragt wollt ihr
abstimmen oder nicht wenn ihr nicht
dafür seid werden wir ganz anders mit
euch umgehen
dann setze ich die Kolonne in Bewegung
aber vorher gibt sich Olga noch einmal
kämpferisch
wir werden wiederkommen sobald das Land
wieder befreit ist
es geht auf einen großen Parkplatz in
der Nähe hier werden die Menschen von
der Polizei befragt kontrolliert und
registriert Inna und ihre Familie sind
aus Carson geflohen ebenfalls seit
Monaten unter russischer Besatzung drei
Tage hat die Fahrt gedauert geschlafen
haben sie teilweise auf der Straße
einfach nur weg
wir sind am 22 losgefahren und jetzt
sind wir hier Gott sei Dank
gefährlich geworden und ich kann einfach
nicht das erfüllen was die von uns
verlangen wir sind Ukrainer
viele Familien sind traumatisiert
Vitalis Schwiegervater saß zwei Wochen
in einem Gefängnis der Russen
all diese Repressionen all das macht ja
auch was mit meinen Kindern und mit uns
auch ständig werden wir bombardiert
Andreas Tölke arbeitet für die
Hilfsorganisation B an angel allein die
hat in den letzten Monaten rund 13.000
Menschen aus dem besetzten Gebieten
herausgeholt viele wollen nicht mehr in
der Ukraine bleiben zumindest erst
einmal selbst wenn man sagt dass nur 20
Prozent vom Land vom Krieg betroffen
sind ist man nirgends in der Ukraine
sicher wir haben das gesehen es sind
Bomben in Levit reingeknallt an der
polnischen Grenze sind Bomben
eingeschlagen also wo in der Ukraine
soll man hinflüchten
[Musik]
und dann heulen wieder die Sirenen
Luftalarm
Anastasia will mit ihrer Familie heute
nach Warschau Berichte von Gräueltaten
machten ihr zunehmend Angst jetzt
braucht sie erst einmal Abstand
bei uns war es relativ normal aber in
den Dörfern dort vergewaltigen sie die
Frauen verspotten und foltern die
Menschen die Helfer rufen noch kommt
bitte zurück wir warten auf euch doch
das wollen sie erst wenn ihre Heimat
wieder befreit ist
wie kann das weitergehen mit diesem
Krieg kann er Kristallkugel haben wir da
alle nicht aber es gibt Menschen die
sich hauptberuflich mit solchen Fragen
beschäftigen und klug analysieren in
eine von ihnen ist Claudia major sie
leitet die Abteilung sicher die
Forschungsabteilung Sicherheitspolitik
an der Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik
und Abend Frau major guten Abend wenn
wir jetzt sehen wie Putin eskaliert also
da hunderttausende Soldaten einzieht und
offenbar auch recht schnell wohl an die
Front schickt was sagt uns das darüber
was er vorhat
ich glaube die mobil machen müssen wir
doch noch mal anders einordnen weil er
wird zwar Truppen bereitstellen können
aber nicht sofort und das werden auch
keine sehr hochwertigen Truppen sein er
muss die erst einbeziehen er muss die
rekrutieren er muss sie ausrüsten er
muss sie ausbilden das geht nicht super
schnell auch weil die Strukturen dafür
nicht mehr da sind und auch die
Ausbilder fehlen zum Beispiel und selbst
wenn die einmal an der Front sind sind
ja die dauerhaften Probleme der
russischen Armee schlechte
Führungsfähigkeit Logistik Probleme
moralprobleme die sind ja nicht weg das
heißt er wird Truppen kriegen aber
wahrscheinlich erst so Anfang 23 und es
werden keine sehr kampfabroben keine
sehr hochwertigen Truppen sein wir
sollten das aber trotzdem nicht klein
reden denn das Signal was er sendet ist
er ist bereit diesen Konflikt in die
Länge zu ziehen und zwar so lange dass
er hoffentlich länger durchhält oder er
glaubt er könnte länger durchhalten als
die westlichen Staaten also setzte im
Prinzip darauf dass hierzulande die
Leute dann oder auch in anderen
europäischen Ländern quasi in die Knie
gehen wenn dann doch die Gasrechnung und
die Stromrechnungen sehr hoch werden und
das ist zu sozialen Verwerfungen
entspricht ja auch immer von diesen
verweichlichten Demokratien auf der dann
setzt in dem Fall das ist in der Tat die
Sorge dass er glaubt dass er diesen
Konflikt länger durchstehen kann als die
westlichen Staaten also er hofft dass
die westliche Unterstützung bröckelt
wenn bei uns die Energiepreise hochgehen
ist möglicherweise zu sozialen Fragen
kommt wenn noch mal neue nukleare Drogen
kommen wir können davon ausgehen dass
Russland noch mal oder das Putin noch
mal nuklear drohen wird wenn man
möglicherweise Bilder sieht über
erfolgreiche scheinreferenten wenn es
auch weitere Berichte gibt wie schwierig
die humanitäre Lage in der Ukraine ist
weil Russland eben die zivile
Infrastruktur vom Krankenhaus bis zum
Wasserwerk platt gemacht hat das heißt
der hofft dass in den westlichen Staaten
die Unterstützung bröckelt und die
Ukraine ist auf die finanzielle und auf
die militärische Unterstützung durch die
westlichen Staaten angewiesen das heißt
er hofft dass er länger durchhält als
die westlichen Staaten und das sollte
man im Kopf haben und ganz stark dagegen
handeln
zum Beispiel mit panzalieferungen die
aber ja die Bundesregierung nicht will
ja ich glaube es ist ein ganzes Paket
das ist die Frage der der finanziellen
Unterstützung die Ukraine als Staat muss
weiter bestehen das heißt sie muss vom
Lehrer Gehalt bis zum Wasserwerk alles
am Laufen halten also die finanzielle
Unterstützung die humanitäre
Unterstützung weil viele Städte zerstört
sind das sind Winter geht und die Frage
ist kann man heizen gibt es Wasser gibt
es Strom aber es ist natürlich auch die
militärische Unterstützung denn die
Frage ist wenn die Ukraine in die Lage
versetzt werden soll ihre Gebiete wieder
zu befreien und wir sehen anhand der
folterberichte aus Issum oder auch aus
Butcher wie notwendig das ist dann
braucht sie eine systematische
langfristige gesicherte Unterstützung
durch die westlichen Staaten an Material
also das heißt auch Schützenpanzer oder
Panzer wenn sie wirklich Gebiete
zurückerobern soll und nicht nur
verteidigen aber da befürchtet ja
offenbar zumindest die deutsche
Bundesregierung dass das zu einer
Eskalation führen könnte also dass dann
da irgendwelche imaginären roten Linien
bei Putin überschritten werden und es
fällt ja zumindest auf dass er und jetzt
zuletzt auch der Außenminister lavrov
noch mal betonten dass die Russland
angegriffen werden wenigsten seine
Existenz bedroht werde das sind ja auch
so ein das ist ja auch so ein wording
wie ist denn der nuklear Doktrin der
Russen steht also ist dieser diese
Drohung nicht doch vielleicht auch
ernster zu nehmen also diese Drohung ist
total verstörend und sie ist total
unverantwortlich sie ist aber wenn man
ehrlich ist auch nicht neu vor Beginn
des Krieges und seit Beginn des Krieges
hat Russland regelmäßig
nuklear gedroht und hat regelmäßig
versucht uns damit nuklear zu erpressen
das heißt den westlichen Staaten in
ihrem Handeln einzuschränken Russland
macht das wahrscheinlich mit zwei Zielen
das eine ist den westlichen Staaten zu
sagen haltet euch raus interveniert
nicht direkt im Krieg das haben die
westlichen Staaten auch nicht gemacht
und das zweite Ziel ist in den
westlichen Öffentlichkeiten also bei uns
für Angst zu sorgen für Sorge vor eine
möglichen Atomwaffeneinsatz zu sorgen so
dass wir die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine reduzieren also nicht so viel
Waffen liefern und auch sonst
vorsichtiger sind aber und das ist mir
ganz wichtig man muss auch sagen dass
das bislang rhetorische Drohungen sind
es gab keine militärische Ableitung also
die Waffen nicht verlegt worden da hat
sich sagen nichts bewegt und man muss
auch sagen dass ein solcher Einsatz für
Russland einen geringen militärischen
Nutzen bringen würde aber sehr hohe
Kosten hätte weil sowohl die USA als
auch die NATO gesagt haben dass sie dann
ihre Rolle im Krieg fundamental
überdenken würden das heißt Russland
wird wahrscheinlich als Paare ja
dastehen und der Westen wurde stärker
eingreifen wenn man das so als so eine
Art Nervenkrieg bezeichnet ist natürlich
wichtig dass die Europäer zusammenhalten
und wird heute in Italien gewählt man
weiß nicht noch nicht wie es ausgeht
aber es war ja ein Bündnis angetreten
bei dem unter anderem Saline dabei ist
der mit Putin T-Shirts auf dem Roten
Platz posierte oder die
Berlusconi-Partei ballusconi hatte dann
nach der Annektion der Krim auch nichts
besseres zu tun als ich damit Putin
ablichten zu lassen wie sehen Sie das
wie sehen sie diese Wahl in der in der
Bedeutung ich glaube das ist die
übergeordnete Frage wie lange Europa
geschlossen bleiben kann Europa und auch
transatlantisch mit den USA das heißt
schaffen wir es als westliche Staaten
diese politische Geschlossenheit waren
die ja erst die Voraussetzung ist die
Ukraine langfristig zu unterstützen oder
lassen wir uns auseinander dividieren
und das ist der Faktor die Hausaufgabe
für alle europäischen Hauptstädte Frau
major ich danke für das Gespräch sehr
gerne
ja Stichwort Italien bis 23 Uhr sind die
Wahllokale dort noch geöffnet von vorher
wird es auch keine Prognosen oder gar
Hochrechnungen geben aufgrund des
italienischen Wahlrechts schließen sich
Parteien oft dort schon vor der Wahl zu
Bündnissen zusammen und die größten
Chancen auf eine Mehrheit der
Parlamentssitze wie eben schon gesagt
wird derzeit eben diesem rechtsbündnis
eingeräumt dass von der sogenannten
postfaschistin Georgia Meloni angeführt
wird aus Italien berichtet Andreas
Postel
wir sind unterwegs ins kleine predapio
auf der Suche nach einer Erklärung warum
die fratellit Italia trotz ihrer
faschistischen Wurzeln in den Umfragen
vorliegen pädago ist der Geburtsort von
Benito Mussolini distanzlos und
unkritisch an jede Ecke faschistische
Symbolik ein Deutsche Museum und jede
Menge Souvenirs der Faschismus ist in
Italien nie ernsthaft aufgearbeitet
worden und kritisch das Verhältnis zu
Hitlers Liebste im Italiener
Italiens war Mussolini ein großer Führer
er hat eine Menge gute Sachen für
Italien gemacht
die ewige Flamme auf Mussolinis Grab ist
das Symbol in der Flagge von fratelli
d'Italia Georgia miloni hat sich von
dieser Symbolik nie wirklich distanziert
einerseits bietet sie sich als moderate
Führungspersönlichkeit an um die
gemäßigte Wählerschaft zu beruhigen
und andererseits hält sie diese Flamme
am Brennen um die Verbindung mit Bauch
Herz und Seele der radikalen
Wählerschaft aufrecht zu erhalten und
das nützt ihr Moderatorinnen
[Musik]
wir Slogan gottfamilie Vaterland noch
vor Beginn des Wahlkampfs Auftritt bei
der spanischen Schwesterpartei VOX
Meloni ohne Maske
natural ja zur natürlichen Familie Nein
zur LGBT Lobby
[Musik]
ja zur christlichen Prinzipien Nein zu
islamistischer Gewalt
ja zur sicheren Grenzen Nein zur
Masseneinwanderung ja zu unseren
Mitbürgern Nein zur internationalen
Finanzwelt ja zur Unabhängigkeit der
Völker Nein zu den Bürokraten in Brüssel
so hört man sie im Wahlkampf nicht sie
stehe jetzt zum transatlantischen
Bündnis zu Europa und zu Ukraine
aufgrund ihrer Nähe zur polnischen peace
Partei anders als ihre Bündnispartner
Berlusconi und Salvini mit ihrer
Russland freundlicheren Haltung der
losconi behauptete jüngst Putin sei in
den Krieg gedrängt wurden Georgia Meloni
hat eine ganz deutliche Meinung zum
Krieg in der Ukraine Matthäus alvini
fordert dagegen jeden Tag das Ende der
EU-Sanktionen deswegen ist für Europa
die Frage viel wichtiger wie viel
Matthäus alvini in einer neuen Regierung
steckt als die wie sehr Meloni von der
draghi-regierung abweichen wird
in den Umfragen zwar zweitstärkste Kraft
ist es dem Sozialdemokraten in ricoletta
nicht gelungen ein breites Wahlbündnis
Gegenrecht zu schmieden die
linkspopulistische fünf sterne-bewegung
scheint besonders im Süden mit sozialen
Versprechungen aufzuholen und könnte am
Ende den rechten Erfolg schmälern
nach einem ungewöhnlich kurzen Wahlkampf
sind es aber vor allem die vielen
unentschlossenen von denen abhängt ob
und wie stark Italien nach rechts rückt
wenn eines der großen
Gründungsmitglieder der Europäischen
Union wählt kann das den anderen
Europäern jedenfalls nicht gleichgültig
sein Florian neuhahn in Brüssel mit wie
viel Sorge schaut man dann dort in
Brüssel nach Italien heute na zumindest
die pro-europäischen Vertreter hier in
Brüssel die halten schon den Atem an und
ich würde sagen mindestens aus zwei
Gründen zum einen nicht wenige fürchten
eine Rückkehr der Euro-Krise wenn sie
vor allem auch die Ausgabenprogramme von
Georgia miloni und Matteo Salvini
anschauen die dann eben auch noch
massive Steuersenkungen für alle
versprochen haben und damit ja womöglich
eine Rückkehr der Eurokrise auch
befördern würden und das zweite
natürlich die gemeinsame Haltung
gegenüber Russlands an diesem Wochenende
hat die EU-Kommission hier in Brüssel
mit den Mitgliedstaaten bereits
verhandelt über die nächste Runde an
Sanktionen gegen Russland aber da ist
eben die Frage offen aber eine neue
italienische Regierung bei diesen
Sanktionen noch mitmachen wird oder ob
sie dann auch angesichts der jüngsten
Äußerungen von Berlusconi ins Lager der
sanktionsgegner um Viktor Orban aus
Ungarn wechselt also für anderthalb
Jahre war Italien hier unter dem
Ex-Premier Mario Draghi von der Liste
der sorgen starten quasi verschwunden
das könnte sich mit dem heutigen
Wahlabend wohl ändern Dankeschön Florian
nach Brüssel
und jetzt geht es bei Dir weiter Heinz
mit den Nachrichten und da zunächst mit
der gasumlage die ist zum ersten Oktober
vorgesehen steht aber jetzt immer mehr
in Frage auch bei Finanzminister Lindner
die gasumlage Macht die Gaspreise noch
teurer da stellt sich die Frage nach der
wirtschaftlichen Sinnhaftigkeit wir
sollten stattdessen über eine
gaspreisbremse nachdenken um die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher und die
Betriebe vor den extremen
Belastungsspitzen zu schützen der SPD
Co-Vorsitzende klingenball sagte in der
ZDF-Sendung Berlin direkt für ihn stehe
die gasumlage politisch auf wackligen
Füßen
das gibt rechtliche Bedenken es gibt
wirtschaftliche bedenken dass alles muss
jetzt in der Regierung schnell geklärt
werden und wenn man einen Weg findet auf
diese gasumlage zu verzichten dann wäre
das ein richtiges Signal an Verbraucher
aber auch in die Unternehmen in
Deutschland die hoch belastet sind
in Iran sind bei den jüngsten Protesten
nach einem Bericht des staatssenders
irip inzwischen 41 Menschen getötet
worden die Polizei nahm nach offiziellen
Angaben alleine im Norden des Landes
mehrere hundert Menschen fest Auslöser
der Proteste ist der Tod der 22 Jahre
alten Iranerin Marsa armini die von der
Sittenpolizei wegen eines Verstoßes
gegen die Kleiderordnung festgenommen
worden war
nordkorea hat nach Angaben aus Südkorea
und Japan erneut eine ballistische
Rakete abgefeuert die Kurzstreckenrakete
sei Richtung Osten ins offene Meer
abgeschossen worden Japans premier
kishida verurteilte den Raketenstart und
beschuldigte Nordkorea mit dem Abschuss
gegen gelten der UN-Resolutionen zu
verstoßen der Raketen der Raketenstart
erfolgte nur wenige Tage nach Ankunft
eines
us-flugzeugträgers in Südkorea
in Kanada wird das Ausmaß der Schäden
deutlich die Wirbelsturm Fiona gestern
angerichtet hat vor allem die Küste
Neufundlands wurde schwer getroffen die
hohen wellenrissen ganze Häuser fort
Premierminister trido spricht von nie
gesehenen Sturmschäden hunderttausende
Menschen waren zeitweise ohne Strom es
soll das Militär bei den Aufräumarbeiten
helfen
und wir blicken noch mal auf Russland
für viele Russen beginnt ja erst jetzt
mit der Mobilmachung ein böses Erwachen
und die Konfrontation mit einem Staat
der keine Gnade kennt andere Teile der
russischen Gesellschaft wissen das schon
lange und sind auch längst geflohen um
nicht im Gefängnis zu landen
Journalisten Künstler Schriftsteller
große Teile der russischen Kulturszene
sind bereits in der Diaspora unter ihnen
Dimitri glukowski einer der populärsten
Bestsellerautoren Russlands Christa
Läpple hat ihnen im Exil getroffen
Leben im Bunker Überleben in einem
Atomkrieg Dimitri klukowskis
science-fiction-romane sind Kult in
Moskau in Kiew und anderswo seine
Geschichten drohen Wirklichkeit zu
werden der 43-Jährige ist einer der
prominentesten Putin-Gegner der Moskauer
meint es ist höchste Zeit den Mund
aufzumachen
dieser Krieg der jetzt gegen Ukraine
angeht ist nicht natürlich
eine ein Krieg des russischen Volkes das
ist ein Krieg des Potenzials seit Juni
dieses Jahres steht tukowski auf der
russischen Fahndungsliste in wenigen
Tagen erscheint sein neues Buch auf
Deutsch es heißt Geschichten aus der
Heimat keine Science Fiction vielmehr
eine schonungslose Nahaufnahme aus
Putins Reich dukowski schildert
Korruption und Willkür der Elite und ein
Volk das in Gleichgültigkeit verhaut da
gibt's eine beherrschende erlernte
Hilflosigkeit bei uns wir glauben
überhaupt nicht dass wir etwas ändern
können ja und es gilt für die sogenannte
einfache Leute was wir für den Volk aber
das geht genauso für den Oligarchen
plukowski selbst lebt im Exil
Schriftsteller hatte im März eine
antikriegspedition mit verfasst nicht
erst seit der Teil Mobilisierung hat in
Russland eine Abstimmung mit den Füßen
begonnen so klukowski seit Kriegsbeginn
haben geschätzt eine halbe Million
Russen ihre Heimat verlassen von denen
die bleiben Wagen nur wenige den offenen
Protest trotz dem sehen wir Tausenden
von Leuten von Menschen die auf die
Straßen gehen um genug zu protestieren
haben
[Musik]
sie machen aber den Protesten nicht weil
sie glauben dass sie etwas ändern können
sondern aus
gewissen Gewissensbisse ja und sie weil
anders würden Sie nicht sich mit sich
weitererleben könnten es gibt diese
mutigen Menschen in Russland klukowski
will ihnen eine Stimme geben auch wenn
er seine Heimat so sehr vermisst wie so
viele Russen im Exil für ihn steht fest
du musst dich von dem Regime trennen
du musst dir den Ukraine helfen
du musst sagen not in my name das ist
nicht ein Krieg für den ich meine Stimme
abgegeben habe ich bin klar dagegen in
seinen Science-Fiction Bestsellern
erzählt er von furchtlosen Helden in
echten Leben steht Lukowski nun draußen
vor der Tür und hofft auf einen raschen
Wandel in seiner Heimat
und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit Meldungen
vom Sport an diesem Wochenende da
starten wir in Berlin zwei Stunden eine
Minute und neun Sekunden das ist erneut
Marathon Weltrekord der ausnahmeläufer
Elliot kippt Joker aus Kenia knackte mit
dieser Zeit seine eigene Bestmarke von
2018 um 30 Sekunden bei den Frauen lief
die äthioperin Tieck ist acifer mit der
drittschnellsten je gelaufenen Zeit ins
Ziel zwei Stunden 15 Minuten 37 Sekunden
bei der Ruder WM in rajici in Tschechien
gab es heute zum Abschluss eine
Goldmedaille für das deutsche Team
Oliver Zeitler im einer hat sie geholt
mit Physis und Wider erlangter mentaler
Stärke hat Oliver Zeitler zurückgefunden
in die Erfolgsspur schon im ersten
Teilabschnitt setzt er sich an die
Spitze und gewinnt vor dem Top
favorisierten Europameister Melvin
Trailer aus den Niederlanden und dem
Briten Graham Thomas das war jetzt das
langer Sinn der volkserlebnis war jetzt
mal wieder gebraucht habe und ja
deswegen bin ich sehr zufrieden die
Medaille ist lediglich Kosmetik für die
bislang schlechteste WM-Bilanz des
Deutschen Ruderverbandes
und zu guter Letzt wie immer sonntags
unser Ausblick Christian von Rechenberg
hat drei Ereignisse ausgewählt die uns
nächste Woche beschäftigen werden
[Musik]
eine Bischofskonferenz wie jede andere
wird die Vollversammlung am Montag wohl
nicht es stehen schwierige Themen ins
Haus sexualisierte Gewalt und Reformen
wie unversöhnlich sich die Lager
innerhalb der katholischen Kirche zum
Teil gegenüberstehen zeigte zuletzt das
Treffen des Synodalen Wegs das mit einem
beinahe eh klar endete Reformer wie
konservative hoffen Auflösungen
wer online shoppen geht der achtet auf
Bewertungen für die Verkäufer sind sie
Visitenkarte und Lebensversicherung was
aber wenn die Kritik der Käufer unwahr
oder unsachlich ist haben die Händler
dann ein Recht auf Löschung im Falle
einer Transaktion bei eBay entscheidet
der BGH dazu am Mittwoch nun
grundsätzlich das Urteil könnte die Art
wie Kunden künftig ihren Kauf bewerten
müssen deutlich ändern
um Kritik geht auch beim zweiten Termin
am Mittwoch die Ministerpräsidenten
haben Redebedarf denn die Länder sollen
in Milliarden Höhe am dritten
Entlastungspaket beteiligt werden nicht
mit uns hört man im Vorfeld Kanzler
Scholz muss wogenglätten sonst droht das
Entlastungspaket im Bundesrat
durchzufallen
und die Wetteraussichten zum Start in
die neue Woche sind so morgen in der
nordwesthälftedichte Wolken und teils
länger anhaltender Regen sonst wechseln
bewölkt und nur vereinzelt Schauer bei
starkem an der Nordsee stürmischen
Südwestwind 10 bis 18 Grad in den
nächsten Tagen viele Wolken wenig Sonne
und immer wieder Regen Höchstwerte 8 bis
15 Grad
das war's dann auch von uns an diesem
Sonntagabend um 00:35 Uhr gibt es dann
die nächste heute Express morgen
erwarten Sie hier Christian Sievers und
Hanna Zimmermann schönen Abend noch auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]